Pendant ces quatre années,
Toutatis a parcouru 8,5 milliards de kilomètres.
Avec une précision fractionnaire
de 0,000000004.
(Rires)
Pourquoi ai-je ce magnifique fragment d'astéroïde?
Parce que, comme tous les voisins,
les astéroïdes rendent visite sans prévenir.
(Rires)
Il y a trois ans aujourd'hui,
un petit astéroïde a explosé sur la ville de Chelyabinsk, en Russie.
Cet objet mesurait environ 19 mètres de largeur,
plus ou moins la taille d'un petit magasin.
Les objets de cette taille touchent la Terre tous les 50 ans environ.
Il y a 66 millions d'années,
un objet énorme toucha la Terre,
causant une extinction massive.
75% des plantes et des espèces animales ont disparu,
y compris, tristement, les dinosaures.
Cet objet mesurait dix kilomètres de largeur environ,
et dix kilomètres est à peu près l'altitude de croisière d'un jet 747.
Quand vous prendrez l'avion,
asseyez-vous près du hublot, regardez dehors et imaginez un rocher si grand
qui, même en restant au sol,
effleure le bord des ailes de l'avion.
Il est si grand qu'il faudrait une minute avant que votre avion ne le survole.
Voilà la taille de l'astéroïde qui toucha la Terre.
Seulement très récemment,
les astéroïdes ont été considérés un vrai danger pour la planète.
Depuis, il y a un grand travail en cours
pour découvrir et cataloguer ces objets.
J'ai la chance de faire partie de ce projet.
Je travaille avec une équipe qui utilise le télescope NEOWISE de la NASA.
NEOWISE n'était pas conçu pour trouver des astéroïdes.
Son but : tourner autour de la Terre et regarder au-delà du système solaire
pour chercher les astres les plus froids, les galaxies les plus éclairées.
Et il l'a très bien fait, pendant sa durée de vie utile de 7 mois.
Mais aujourd'hui, six ans plus tard, il est encore actif.
On l'a réutilisé pour chercher et analyser les astéroïdes.
Et bien qu'il soit un super petit robot spatial,
aujourd'hui on dirait une vieille voiture.
Le cryogène censé réfrigérer ses capteurs a disparu depuis longtemps
donc on blague que « sa climatisation est cassée ».
Actuellement, il a 1 480 millions de kilomètres au compteur,
mais il fonctionne très bien
et prend fidèlement des photos du ciel toutes les 11 secondes.
Depuis que j'ai pris la parole, il a déjà pris 23 photos.
NEOWISE est si précieux
parce qu'il voit le ciel via des infrarouges thermiques.
Cela signifie qu'au lieu de voir la lumière reflétée par les astéroïdes,
NEOWISE voit leur chaleur.
Cette capacité est fondamentale, vu que certains astéroïdes sont vraiment noir
et il est difficile voire impossible de les voir avec d'autres télescopes.
Tous les astéroïdes, éclairés ou noirs, brillent pour NEOWISE.
Les astronomes utilisent toutes les techniques à leur disposition
pour découvrir et étudier les astéroïdes.
En 2010, une étape historique a été atteinte.
La communauté a découvert plus de 90% des astéroïdes
qui mesurent plus d'un kilomètre.
Des objets capables de détruire la Terre.
Mais le travail n'est pas fini.
Un objet de 140 mètres ou plus pourrait décimer un pays de taille moyenne.
Jusqu'à maintenant, nous en avons découvert seulement 25%.
Nous devons continuer à rechercher des astéroïdes dans le ciel.
Nous sommes la seule espèce qui comprend les calculs
ou qui construit des télescopes.
Nous savons comment trouver ces objets.
C'est notre responsabilité.
Si on découvrait un astéroïde dangereux à temps,
on pourrait le repousser loin.
Contrairement aux tremblements de terre, ouragans et éruptions,
l'impact d'un astéroïde peut être prévu avec précision
et évité.
Ce qu'on doit faire c'est quadriller l'espace proche de la Terre.
On doit continuer à sonder le ciel.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)